you
a Wilco Stark vice president of strategy
for Daimler welcome to Stanford and
thank you very much thank you for coming
to the industrialist dilemma or excited
to have you in class
today and you know we wanted to get
started by asking you at a high level
what are your responsibilities at diners
in charge of strategy and product
planning what do you do on an everyday
basis at the company actually my
responsibility is to define the future
of Daimler and in particular you know
mercedes-benz cars are we're facing a
lot of challenges in the automotive
industry so my key work is actually to
manage the transformation process
because to identify the trends is one
thing what is even more important really
to manage for transformation process for
the whole company to stay also in the
next 100 years successful so let's start
with some of those transformations that
are happening externally what are the
three biggest things that keep you up at
night
as you think about Daimler and Mercedes
on a go-forward basis actually it's
talking over I said I'm about four major
trends and it's on the one hand side its
connectivity it's a change to electric
cars and it's autonomous driving and
it's everything about shared mobility
and mobility of the future and the key
challenge is actually not managing these
four trends but also the combination of
these trends because the company who
really manages the combination of his
four trends will define the future of
mobility and but it's also quite
challenging there are so many
regulations and different regulations if
it comes to the u.s. if it comes to
Europe if it comes to China and we have
to cope with these generate various
regulations and that's also a big big
challenge and it costs us a lot of money
so what business do you think Daimler is
in if you think about companies over 130
years old or almost 130 years old
what business is the firm in today
that's a pretty good question actually
you know our fundamental key business is
still building producing developing cars
so this is a backbone of Daimler and of
course trucks and of mercedes-benz cars
but you know the world is changing and
it's not only about owning a car
it's all about renting sharing a car
white herring etc and we have to to cope
with all these trends so I'm the one
hand side key work is still done on
building the best cars of the world but
we have to offer our customers a
completely new platform and services so
that we can cope with these trends and
have a wide answer to our customers
because but it's very very important
from our perspective we do not want to
lose the direct customer interface now
how would that impact how you work with
your channel and your dealers and all
these people who have been with you for
a long time as the product that you sell
on the services that you sell change
pretty dramatically over the next decade
I think this is actually you know the
key challenge because we have to manage
this transformation process of course
number one hand side for our traditional
customers we still need with dealerships
but for our new customers we are looking
for direct channel you know and we are
selling we're also selling the cars over
the internet but we also have contracts
with our dealers and this is the whole
transformation process we have to manage
and this is maybe one challenge but even
bigger challenge is the transformation
busy in our whole product portfolio if
it comes to electrification if it comes
to autonomous driving because the whole
platform architecture of an electric car
is completely different compared to a
combustion engine car and this means we
have to invest billions and billions of
dollars or euros to cope with his stance
and to come up with completely new
platform architectures take it as an
example autonomous driving we strongly
believe that in the future of mobility
autonomous driving will be a big part of
it mm-hmm and this also includes sharing
mobility white healing services etc so I
give you an example you know you bought
quite well in the u.s. lyft etcetera
Diddy in China actually we do as Dom law
half the same in Germany in Europe it's
called my taxi it's more or less the
same app but of course we have to cope
with the regulations of a taxi business
in Germany in Europe so that's a
slightly different story but it's
actually it's actually completely the
same so we are offering our services our
customers all these services and that's
very important because you know
our strategy is we want to build and
define the future of mobility it's not
the future of a car it's a future of
mobility
okay so Daimler historically has been an
engineering powerhouse I mean some of
the greatest engineering minds and some
of the greatest cars that have been
built we were talking about them earlier
the s-class series etc and now as
mobility changes you have to bring in
new competencies and new skill sets talk
a bit about how you bring those new
behaviors those new competencies inside
of the firm and what do you do with the
existing people inside of the
organization so they don't feel like
maybe they're being left behind or
they're just the old part of the
business yeah yeah so first of all would
be due behalf we have to be pretty good
in our core business yeah because this
will they still be the backbone of our
business but we have to of course we
have to all become very digital natives
because all these trends connectivity
autonomous driving sharing mobility also
electrification at the end is given by
digitalization so we initiated an
initiative called a digital life at
Daimler okay so we really try to bring
the digital life you know what really
affects the customer into our
organization so we are taking hackathons
open spaces we have a digital life day
and of course we do it you know in all
in all our countries so we do it in
China we do it in Europe we do it in the
US so that's very very important and we
also do did a set up some cultural
changes and we call it leadership 2020
so what do we mean with leadership 2020
we set up a team actually of 50 to 60
employees and said yoga from the whole
organization across the world and said
you have to define what is leadership
2020 what does this actually mean so
it's actually coming all the ideas from
the bottom off the organization this is
now what we are going to implement
across time law this in the next this in
the next years so really turn it upside
down okay now corporate transformations
and it's been studied for decades and
decades how do you make sure that
Daimler isn't just and you know
now we're all wearing blue jeans when we
go into work and now we're all hiring
young people who can grow beards and
they're all on their their their iPhones
or their Android smartphones how do you
make sure that that Daimler continues to
execute but in the same token brings
that DNA in and how do you know if
you're succeeding that's a pretty good
question you know we keep challenges and
we haven't find the right answer yet
regarding all these four trends
connectivity autonomous driving shape
mobility electrification the key
challenges identification of the trends
is a piece of cake okay that's pretty
easy also to come up with the right
centers is not a piece of cake the key
challenge at the end this combination of
three strands to find the right answers
to really offer all the services in the
combination and second you know we still
have our core business so we have to
decide where to invest our money mm-hmm
the key challenges we have to spend
still billions of dollars into our core
business to keep these regulations I
give you an example and emission
standards if you take John on vues
Europe doesn't matter are getting
tougher and tougher mm-hmm this means we
still have to invest in combustion
engines in billion of dollars and we
have to change this on the other hand
side we of course have to invest in
electric vehicles which cost us even
more right yeah this is the challenge to
really manage risk transformation
process and what is also quite important
from a cultural perspective we don't you
know we don't want to have an atmosphere
where we have on the one hand side one
part of my organization which is a
feeling of all the economy and the other
part of the organization as a feeling of
new economy because we're working on the
new topics etc so that's very very
important to not have a break through
this organization because when the
people have you know I'm old economy I
might if the losing team etc so this is
very very important but that's not going
to happen how do you look at a company
like Tesla which actually doesn't have
the legacy in history and how do you
compete against an organization which
doesn't have to manage simultaneously
the past and the present and the future
well what's Daimler's competitive
advantage and or challenges in going up
against a firm like that
I think the the big advantage of Tesla
is actually you know they can push
everything and they're electric vehicles
and we have to manage the transition
unless a big big devil they're big big
difference and she'll and should
actually be as a Daimler or
mercedes-benz cows are facing but on the
other hand we have a lot of experience
we have 130 years of experience in
building cars in defining quality
there's no difference if it's a
combustion engine or electric vehicle
the touch and feel of a car you know and
how it the weight of the car etc the
viscosity components etc so that is our
experience and that's you know from our
perspective where we come up with an
electric vehicle and the next years we
strongly believe it will be the best
electric vehicle in the world so I think
I read Daimler was gonna invest 11
billion dollars or 11 billion euros yeah
into electric vehicles what are those
discussions like internally where
someone says you know it's a lot of
money and you've got the existing
businesses which are always under
resourced and always need more heads and
always need more dollars
how do those discussions happen inside
of the organization actually you know be
decided within our mercedes-benz cars
Executive Committee it's actually a bet
but it's very important because we
strongly believe electric vehicles are
coming because we are driven by the
legislation around the globe so if you
take China for example you know Stage
five in 2025 means four liters per
hundred kilometers mm-hmm so this
actually means we have to come up is a
electrification be pure electric vehicle
or plugins of up to 30% because
otherwise we are not going to meet the
co2 targets yeah but what is even more
important to manage the transformation
process to spend nine billion or ten
billion that's one part of a story but
you know the key challenges but nobody
knows what kind of mix do we have in
2025 on a global level will it be 10
percent will it be 15 percent will it be
20 percent or even 25 percent so what we
did is actually we said
the most important part is to be hundred
percent flexible so what do I mean with
flexibility we want to be hundred
percent flexible within our organization
within the production network mm-hmm
across the whole value chain so this
means we put the car the electric
vehicle on the same production line okay
that's a combustion engine car so
factories can be switched very quick and
switch and we can dress this in this MB
mixer so that's I think that's the most
important part okay because for one
simple reason
we electric vehicles if it really comes
to a tipping point to electric vehicles
it won't be additional volume right yeah
so our assumption is if it be 70 80
percent of course cannibalization right
within our portfolio so which means
combustion engine or traditional cars
going down the other one is going up and
therefore flexibility is the most
important part so Daimler and Mercedes
are global businesses I believe I read
that 40 to 45 percent of the sales are
in Europe 20 to 25 percent in the NAFTA
area and the balance largely in Asia
yeah how does Daimler thinking about
different regions different regulations
and the complexities that come with that
balance that with kind of what might be
a uniquely European perspective that
Daimler might have being in Germany
where that might inform some of the
decisions that might be different than
how American companies or some of the
other Asian companies might look at how
they're addressing these same challenges
from a design language from a styling
language via a German or European
company yeah and also from a quality
perspective for Metuchen fear I think
this is actually the root of our company
but we have to cope with the customer
requirements in the different regions so
therefore we have a dedicated portfolio
for China for example because China
would like to have a long-wheelbase you
know would like to have a premier
focuses on four-cylinder engines and
also our top of the range Mercedes
Maybach is very very successful in China
so it's very very important to see what
kind of requirements do we have in the
different regions when I give you
another example you know we are here at
Stanford University in silicon
Meli but what is also important if it
comes to digitalization but Chinese
customers are the most digital offend
people around the globe so they all live
in Alibaba you know intense and sad and
be so super apps you know on a daily
basis even hours hours and they're doing
everything paying etc right within
missing their app right now and
therefore a digitalization of the whole
connectivity stuff it's very very
important from our perspective China is
really the most advanced also from a
customer behavior point of view which
and therefore we have to come up as a
company right as a global leader of
premium cars they serve wide answers to
the customers in the different regions
do you think your revenue mix changes as
you look to add digital services and
have ongoing contact with the customers
do you need to think differently about
not just the the automobiles that they
drive and Daimler and Mercedes have
always met you know performance and high
quality now all of a sudden you've got
to think about information services
music entertainment services music video
etc how does Daimler make sure that it's
participating in those vectors as well I
think that's it's very important and
maybe first of all you know also from a
regional perspective business change and
so China is becoming more and more
important he actually had a mix ten
years ago of a 1% 2% in China and it's
now 20 to 23 percent and it's rising
with double-digit growth rates so this
is just from a regional perspective
getting back to the cars and to the
services of course we see a change so we
have to add additional services this is
a customer requirement and the key
challenge once again is how to make
money out of resurfaces I give you an
example if it comes to streaming for
example streaming music film movies etc
the key challenges in China if you have
a Alibaba returns and WeChat app is all
for free right it's all for free so
Chinese customers are not willing to pay
for it because they already have it for
real yeah
and therefore the key challenge is what
can be what kind of specific services
can be offered to our customers and also
charts whiskers or
this is Vicki challenged so we come up
with some some ideas for example our
smart business you can have a delivery
of your parcel from from Amazon for
example into your smart okay yeah so
that's pretty cool and there are also
other ideas which we come up and really
at the end you know the challenges how
which services can be charged to make
them money out of it okay so our people
are still gonna really want to drive in
the future if we think about Mercedes
cars and how much fun they are to drive
and yeah the the rush the physical and
emotional rush we get from driving a
great sports car as things become more
autonomous does that become less
important even just to me and if it does
matter just to adjust to a smaller sub
segment of the population from my
perspective I think beyond a pretty good
starting situation as a premium car
manufacturer for one simple reason
because if it comes to right healing
autonomous driving and we call it over
car services at the end you know
Retriever see in a few years from now in
in the streets premium is becoming more
affordable mm-hmm and that's a big big
universe a big advantage of Mercedes
Benz because you know just to order to
to book a white hair link you know on a
Mercedes just cost you a few cents more
compared to a volume common volume car
yeah and I think you know from our
perspective availab big market really
wolf for premium cars because premium in
all ways why telling mobility services
will become much more affordable to a
lot of people and therefore we see a big
potential in this market so in the
spirit of paranoia and I used to work
for a Negro but Intel there times only
the paranoid survive if 10 years from
now Daimler were struggling and I'm
we're we're having a hard time what do
you think would be the biggest reason
that that might be the case the spirit
of the question is what keeps you up at
night what's your biggest worry is you
think about how Daimler needs to evolve
over the next decade given all the
changes happening in the industry from
my perspective the biggest challenges to
cope with these trends I think we can
manage it but at the end really to make
a business case out of it and we have
the advantage you know there have been a
lot of rumors especially among
they're Silicon Valley companies they
want to enter the automotive business
automotive business is very very asset
intensive so they have not the highest
interest actually to enter our core
business but we want to be between the
customer and we automotive industry
mm-hmm so that's the key challenge we
are facing we don't want to become at
the end the foxconn of Apple wait just
to get just again just to give you an
example and this is actually the key
challenge and what I see as a major
challenge is really the the investment
we need to make for all these twins and
how does it affect our bottom line
mm-hmm I'd be still have not so many
answers how to make money out of these
twins because as I told you the example
in China it's all for free some customer
is not willing to pay for us so to offer
B services to build up the IT
infrastructure for holdback engines are
gonna cost billions or millions of
dollars and therefore really to make at
the end a business case out of it this
is the key challenge and you know for
God's sake we have a pretty good
starting point because envision message
burn scars we have for the time being
return on sales of 10% but that's a key
challenge last question for you is the
head of strategy for Daimler where do
you spend your time if you look at your
calendar and your diary over a week what
percentage of your time do you spend on
on which projects it's actually the most
of my time is managing the
transformation process so connectivity
autonomous driving electrification of a
drive time and also of a whole product
portfolio and of course sharing mobility
and and this is also very very important
we have to team up and this is also a
big part of my time with the best
partners in the world to manage these
challenges bead whitening services with
autonomous driving bead electrification
so this is such a complex world you
cannot do it by our own we have to team
up as partners this is the best actually
in the world and that's very important
so we have to define what are our
internal competences and then do we have
where do we have to add conveyances and
if you take just an example you know
there's been a lot of articles or
something personal all the economy and
you will economy friends and enemies and
we created this you know with new word
for enemies and at the end I think
that's very very important because if
you wanted a fine mobility of the future
we cannot do it by our own we have to
team up with partners and this means we
have to team up with partners in the
Western world and even more important
and it even more important but you know
also quite important of course with
partners in China right
and so the hard part will be knowing
what are these other partners who are
large organizations like Daimler when
are they friends and what are the
enemies and sometimes when they're both
yeah will co-star thank you for coming
to Stanford thank you very much thanks
[Music]